foreign
for the upcoming emancipation Day
celebration in Bridgetown Barbados
other remnants of its Colonial past the
Island's crop over Festival has its
Origins on the sugar cane plantations
during the days of the transatlantic
slave trade Educators like Sophia Graves
say the holiday doesn't seek to erase
the past but rather flip the script
turning the date into a celebration of
cultural heritage so when we
a lot of the Traditions that even were
brought here by the persons who had
enslaved us but we would have
transformed them into movements that we
would have made for our celebration and
also to appreciate despite the
challenges we can say our people have a
sense of resilience and they can take a
lot and transform it into something
beautiful
the dances are also chock full of
symbolism we enjoy the color and the
color of the Caribbean we can refashion
it as
in terms of very dance and we remove it
talks about all of that as we move
around with the eyelashes and it also
reflects some of our music movements as
we said earlier where we're talking
about those strong movements those
African movements coming through
on Barbados the legacy of slavery
remains alive sugarcane plantations some
dating back hundreds of years still
cover the landscape
but at the Barbados Museum art historian
Alessandra Cummings says time has
allowed barbadians to reverse the
narrative on the past that's part of the
reason why we've hung this Gallery this
way it's a kind of retelling of
traditional narratives narratives that
until fairly recently only in the last
20 or 30 years have had to be
Rewritten
reconceptualized and Rewritten
particularly when we were talking about
education for young people but until
young people see themselves
in terms of individuals taking charge of
a narrative they don't get that they
have a right to identify themselves in a
particular way it was only in 2021 that
Barbados became a republic and in many
ways the fledgling democracy is still
shaping its identity though Barbados has
has yet to recover after centuries of
slavery it's a nation that's not only
reclaimed The Narrative over its history
but that's emerged as a global leader in
reparative Justice
this year Barbados hosted a first of its
kind International Summit on reparations
for slavery Paving the way for other
former colonies and the descendants of
enslaved persons to demand reparations
from European countries before
International courts
thank you
as Barbados looks toward a brighter
future its strength as a society founded
on the horrors of the slave trade now
Builds on a strong sense of remembrance
and cultural Pride
Manuel rapalo Al Jazeera Bridgetown
Barbados
foreign